so i'm standing at the front door and i
did have a vodka i'll never forget that
i said i'll have a vodka because i
wanted to calm down a little bit i'm
going to meet the husband of a woman i'm
sleeping with almost a year
and i'm looking out the window i see a
big black fleetwood broom pull up
big caddy spoke wheels
dark windows pulls in
and i'm watching i want to see what he
looks like at that first impression
he gets out of the car
dark sunglasses it's dark out at night
he's still got dark sunglasses on
sport jacket dressed like
he once told me john gotti learned how
to dress for me okay later on
dressed just like that i mean shop
and i won't say he walked to the door
because it was more of a swagger
he had a presence in his walk that as he
was coming to the door it registered i
said this is not because i had an
uncloud but who's around guys like this
and i said this is no doctor or salesman
i said you know and later on i had said
if you look in the dictionary
on the mobster there's a picture of him
model uh what's that other word uh
uh just a perfect example of of a
gangster
so he comes up the steps
i open the door
and i put my hand out i says uh
i'm larry
he says i'm greg
so we shake hands he smiles very nice
happy to meet me but all along i thought
his name was charles
that's the first
time i learned his name was greg she
told you it's charles she told me he was
charles got it okay charles shearer
there's a whole story behind that and i
i you know it's not even my place to get
into it but with an ex
husband or an ex-boyfriend but
he was
charles shiro to me up until that minute
so he goes in he's gonna
freshen up change a little bit whatever
he goes and i go to linde i said lin i
thought his name was greg
he said he's charlie i i s charlie i
thought you know she says oh no he just
uses that name charlie
i said people just use all the names i
it's like she said it like it's normal
you still don't know what he does no no
but like i said that struck to the house
i said this is a man's man i mean it's a
guy got it you know
so
he comes back in and he has two scotches
now i had vodka i even then i didn't
want to mix but i didn't say no i took a
scotch and we sipped it together he
talked a little bit he started telling
me about the company we're going to meet
these two guys one's a lawyer one's an
accountant they were on the board of
this company very real and it wasn't it
turned out to be real uh so anyway that
night i meet him and we go to the
restaurant
so she walk into the car she goes to
grab my arm
and i had to move away from the lake
like what are you doing yeah he was in
front of us let us walk behind
so anyway we get to the restaurant
and
i meet the two fellows and he doesn't
recommend he doesn't
say i want to propose larry to be the
sales manager
he tells them both uh larry's going to
be our sales manager
i said okay that's how you need a resume
or anything you've never sold you never
did nothing no no well you are now yeah
yeah
so yeah so and you got a promotion
yourself manager
sales manager right off the bat
so
anyway after this night
i start working for him and he tells me
i have to come to the office every day
which turns out to be a social club so i
start meeting other guys and i'll get
more into that
but before all this happens you know i'm
going out to different avenues
they give me a list of addresses to go
to where i can uh service their fire
extinguisher and then try to sell them
paper products
and
the the addresses they gave me were all
hot i was going to get them i walked in
they were expecting me i got the account
so i built a little portfolio right off
the bat
if they didn't say yes
or i went to a place called they told me
you can go into other stores in the same
area but start with this one say yes
and they would tell me no i'd go back to
the club and i'd say well these four
guys weren't interested and greg says
all right carmine those carmine in
carmine gets the addresses go back there
the next day go back again tomorrow i go
back the next day they treat me like uh
i don't see al capone like a senator a
neighborhood
uh politician are you speculating at
this time like what's going on of course
no no now i see the club i know he's i
know he's you know he's connected at
this point yeah okay yeah again i know
he's what he is was greg a known face
and a name that you no he's a low-key
guy he's located is he a cop at that
time or not no he never i'm gonna tell
you he never became a capital until the
very end got it okay they bypassed him
for his son
something i thought they asked him about
june okay and yeah greg jr told me no
they bypassed my father and this
discussion came
because of what came out years later and
i don't want to tip my mission let's get
to that so yeah yeah uh
so uh now i got this position i see the
influence i'm getting these uh uh
accounts
and this goes on for a few months but
while it's going on he's helping me he's
building me up he's telling these other
guys about me that i'm his nephew and we
treat him you know i mean it's off the
charts so i start feeling very very
guilty and i'm starting to
tell linda we have to stop we can't do
this this isn't right i mean i i can't
go on like this so if you like this sort
of short clip from an interview i did
click over here to watch the entire
interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]